Hallöchen zusammen! Wir machen heute ein richtig leckeres Rezept mit Erdbeeren.
Diesmal hab ich mir gedacht wir machen einen Erdbeermilch-Kuchen.
Wer kennt's noch aus der Schule? Da gab's immer Kaba, Erdbeermilch, Vanillemilch..
Ich hab das nie bekommen! Hamza, du?
[Hamza] Ab und zu!
[Kiki] Ab und zu?
[Hamza] Ja!
Also ich hab das nie bekommen und wenn mal jemand krank war, dann durfte man sich immer eins nehmen.
Da war ich immer voll happy, dass ich auch mal probieren durfte!
Auf jeden Fall machen wir einen Erdbeermilch-Kuchen.
Der wird so ähnlich sein wie Trilece, nur eben auf eine ganz andere Art und Weise.
Und ich starte jetzt dafür mit dem fluffigen Teig.
Ich mach das jetzt mit der Küchenmaschine, ihr dürft aber auch euer Handrührgerät benutzen.
Dafür erstmal die Eier schön sauber trennen. Es darf nichts vom Eigelb in das Eiweiß gelangen
und die Schüssel sollte auch schön sauber und fettfrei sein.
Das ist das letzte Ei und ein richtig guter Tipp: Falls euch mal doch Eigelb da reinfällt,
dann nicht mit 'nem Löffel oder mit dem Finger rauspulen, sondern mit der Eierschale,
dann kriegt ihr das garantiert immer!
So, und da gebe ich jetzt noch 'ne Prise - Ach komm, das nehme ich noch mit!
Da gebe ich jetzt noch 'ne Prise Salz rein und fange an, das zu schlagen.
Erstmal 30 Sekunden und danach gebe ich Zucker dazu
und dann weitere 2min lang bis so 'ne richtig schöne Baisermasse entsteht.
Ich muss noch meinen Aufsatz holen. Da war ich ein bisschen unvorbereitet, sorry!
Jetzt aber!
Jetzt haben wir eine richtig schöne, feste Baisermasse.
Übrigens: Die ganz genauen Mengenangaben, die schreibe ich euch wie immer hier unten in die Videobeschreibung.
Ich mache jetzt weiter mit dem Eigelb, das werde ich jetzt hier nach und nach unterrühren
und gerade solange rühren, bis es sich wirklich verbunden hat.
Ihr müsst nicht unnötig lange rühren, das wäre dann nicht so förderlich.
Und danach verrühre ich die trockenen Zutaten miteinander.
Die Maschine habe ich jetzt weggestellt, wir machen weiter mit unserem Teigschaber.
Ihr kennt's nicht anders: Wir müssen das jetzt mit ganz viel Liebe unterheben.
Ich siebe das vorher nochmal damit auch keine Klümpchen entstehen.
Gerade so beim Backpulver habe ich das Gefühl, dass am Ende noch so ein paar Klümpchen drin sind.
Und dann richtig schön von außen nach innen mit dem Teigschaber unterheben.
Das Wichtigste bei diesem Rezept ist wirklich dieser fluffige Teig werden, Leute! Der muss einfach perfekt sein.
Ansonsten bringt das alles nichts. Und ich habe jetzt hier auch schon direkt meine Auflaufform bereit.
Einen Backrahmen empfehle ich tatsächlich nicht bei diesem Rezept weil wir tränken das ja
à la Trilece später noch mit 'nem schönen Guss.
Und da würde euch nur alles auslaufen, daher nicht wirklich förderlich.
So, mein Teig ist fertig, ich hole mir jetzt die Auflaufform.
Und zwar hat die jetzt die jetzt die Maße 17x25cm.
Wenn ihr jetzt hier und da mal 1cm variiert, ist das gar kein Problem.
Aber beachtet dann natürlich: Falls ihr jetzt 'ne viel größere Auflaufform habt, dann wird euer Teig viel flacher.
Ihr könnt aber auch meine Umrechnungstabelle auf meiner Webseite benutzen, verlinke ich euch auch unten in die Infobox.
Ein Backpapier auf den Boden legen..
Ah, wisst ihr, was ich mache?
Ich werde die ein bisschen befeuchten, dann klebt nämlich mein Backpapier ein bisschen besser am Boden.
Jaa, schon viel besser!
Und jetzt einmal den Teig drauf verteilen und dann noch ein bisschen glatt verstreichen.
*lacht*
Während der Backofen arbeitet, mache ich die leckere Erdbeermilch.
Ich habe jetzt Erdbeeren gehabt, die sehen nicht mehr ganz so hübsch aus
aber ich finde das passt ja perfekt, denn die werden jetzt sowieso püriert.
Die Hübschen habe ich mir für die Deko kurz zur Seite gestellt.
Und da nehme ich jetzt einfach nur meinen Pürierstab.
Ihr dürft auch zwischendurch ein paar Schlücke Wasser dazugeben.
Wichtig ist, dass wir die jetzt einfach nur schön - *lacht*
Wichtig ist, dass wir die einfach nur schön fein pürieren
und anschließend werde ich sie auch noch durch ein feines Sieb passieren denn ich mag die Stückchen nicht so da drin.
Okay, krass! Wasser brauchte ich heute tatsächlich gar nicht.
Meine Erdbeeren scheinen doch sehr wässrig zu sein.
Und jetzt einmal schön passieren.
Ich mach's so, dass ich mir gleich schon so ca. 3EL schonmal an die Seite nehme für die Dekoration.
Weil ich finde on top brauchen wir halt auch nochmal so ein bisschen - so einen kleinen Farbklecks!
Und ich persönlich mag im Mund das Gefühl von diesen kleinen Stückchen nicht.
Wenn euch das nichts ausmacht, dann müsst ihr das jetzt nicht sieben. Gar kein Problem!
So, die passierten Erdbeeren jetzt einmal reingeben, natürlich bis auf die 2-3EL.
Die brauche ich - oah, das sieht schon gut aus!
So, die brauche ich für die Deko.
Ja hört mal! Hamza, jetzt sag doch auch mal was! Sieht gut aus!
[Hamza] Das sieht nach Mädelsabend aus!
[Kiki] Das sieht nach Mädelsabend aus! *lacht*
Ich gebe da jetzt Vanilleextrakt - Leute, Vanilleextrakt hebt's einfach nochmal auf so ein anderes Level! -
Ich hab in den Teig auch kein Vanilleextrakt gegeben weil ich dachte ich geb's lieber jetzt hier rein.
Ich verbacke mein Vanille gar nicht erst sondern geb's hier rein.
Und gleich tränken wir den Boden damit.
Ich hab grad auf den Ofen geguckt - 12min braucht er noch.
Ich gebe jetzt hier noch Sahne mit rein. Was Fettiges brauchen wir da auch noch drin, das ist nochmal..
Vertraut mir, macht das einfach.
Und dann Puderzucker.
Im Teig habe ich tatsächlich ganz wenig Zucker genommen, ich hab's da richtig reduziert.
Hier habe ich auch nur ein bisschen Puderzucker, also es wird gar nicht so richtig süß später,
sondern einfach nur.. es wird genau richtig Leute. So, oh!
Das ist für mich die perfekte Erdbeermilchfarbe.
Genau so wünsche ich mir das!
Nein Spaß! *lacht*
So, was habe ich jetzt noch tun?
Ich habe ja jetzt noch so um die 10min bis mein Boden aus dem Ofen kommt.
Ich würd vorschlagen ich zeige euch jetzt wie die Creme funktioniert!
Für obendrüber mache ich jetzt nämlich eine leckere Sahne-Quarkcreme.
Dafür ganz kalte Schlagsahne in eine kalte Schüssel geben, also sie sollte jetzt nicht warm sein.
Und jetzt schlage ich das Ganze.
Ich benutze übrigens heute kein Sahnefest weil das wird so ein richtig fluffiges Dessert.
Also wir brauchen gar kein Sahnefest. Es muss ja auch nicht standfest sein sondern es soll richtig schön cremig und fluffig sein.
Und jetzt einfach schlagen und danach gebe ich Puderzucker, Vanilleextrakt und Sahnequark noch mit rein.
Aber erst wenn's steif ist!
So, Sahne ist steif.
Ich glaub ich mach nicht den Überkopftest weil.. die ist steif!
Aber ohne Sahnefest traue ich mich den Test nicht!
Ich nehme übrigens Puderzucker weil Kristallzucker würde sich da jetzt wahrscheinlich ein bisschen schwerer drin auflösen
bzw. so ist man einfach auf der sicheren Seite, dass man später keine Zuckerkristalle mehr im Mund spürt.
Vanilleextrakt.. Und ich nehme halt Sahnequark, einfach wegen des Geschmacks.
20%-igen habe ich hier, ihr könntet auch 40%-igen nehmen.
Natürlich dürft ihr auch Magerquark verwenden.
Also das ist gar kein Problem aber ich finde halt geschmacklich passt das hier einfach besser.
Die Reste schabe ich gleich noch aus. Und jetzt kurz verrühren und fertig!
Uuund fertig!
[Kiki] Vanillepünktchen! Siehst du sie?
[Hamza] Yes!
So, der Boden ist fertig gebacken!
Ich habe ihn jetzt aber auch nochmal 4-5min lang ausdampfen lassen.
Und jetzt nehmt ihr einmal etwas Schmales wie z.B. eine Winkelpalette und dann einmal..
Am L- Am Lang entrangfahren wollte ich sagen, oh mein Gott!
Am Rand entlangfahren, oh mein Gott! *lacht*
So, einmal hier am Rand.. Wir haben ja Backpapier unten drunter getan wollte ich sagen,
wie soll man sonst da rankommen?
Genau, wir wollen das ja jetzt einmal rausnehmen.
Dafür nehme ich mir jetzt hier einfach so einen Tortenretter, ihr könnt einfach irgendwas Flaches nehmen.
Macht euch da keinen Stress. Und dann einmal stürzen.
So, und dafür war jetzt unser Backpapier gut, das wollte ich nämlich gerade sagen.
Weil sonst hätte euch das da am Boden geklebt und das wäre voll die Katastrophe geworden!
Und so haben wir keinen Stress.
Umgedreht da reinlegen damit schön die Poren offen sind
und die Erdbeermilch da richtig schön eingesogen werden kann.
So. Oh Gott, das riecht schon so gut!
[Hamza] Also im Endeffekt ist es so Trilece-mäßig, oder?
[Kiki] Es ist wie Trilece!
Ich nehme jetzt eine Gabel und steche da jetzt doch nochmal rein.
[Kiki] Wie Spongebob!
[Hamza] Aber mit Zahnstocher geht das jetzt auch, ne?
Ja, also ich hatte das eigentlich hier, ich wollte eigentlich zeigen:
Stäbchenprobe - gucken, ob Teig dranhängt. Wenn nicht, dann ist er gar. Das wollte ich euch zeigen.
Aber man könnte das auch so durchlöchern.
Man muss jetzt auch nicht so übertreiben. Wir haben's ja umgedreht und dadurch sind die Poren schon offen.
Und jetzt - Das ist jetzt hier noch lauwarm und das ist auch in Ordnung -
Und jetzt kommt unsere kalte Erdbeermilch da einmal drüber.
Man denkt immer das ist so viel aber es ist genau richtig!
Das darf sich ja hier auch nochmal verteilen.. so!
Das Ganze ist jetzt noch.. ist das noch warm?
Es ist eigentlich schon kalt, durch die kalte Milch ist es eigentlich schon kalt.
Das heißt ich könnte jetzt direkt mein Topping draufgeben!
Die kalte Milch haben wir jetzt drübergegossen und dadurch ist der ganze Kuchen jetzt schon erkaltet.
Tut mir bitte einen Gefallen: Geht mal mit der Hand einmal drüber und fühlt.
Wenn da noch Wärme kommt, dann wartet und lasst ihn ½h im Kühlschrank abkühlen.
Bei mir ist er jetzt schon kalt und daher kann ich direkt weitermachen.
Ich gebe jetzt diese fluffige, fluffige Creme obendrauf!
Oh mein Gott, das ist der Inbegriff von Fluffigkeit!
Und ich mache das jetzt auch extra so mit dem Teigschaber.
Holt euch gar keine Winkelpalette und macht das gar nicht so perfekt, sondern einfach wie Wolken!
[Hamza] Ich finde das sieht auch so schick aus!
[Kiki] Ja, finde ich auch.
Warte, lass mich noch mal hier so ein bisschen diese Swirls reinmachen
damit das so richtig fluffig aussieht.
[Kiki] Oah, dat macht Spaß Hamza!
[Hamza] Hast du Spaß anner Backen?
[Kiki] Ich hab Spaß anner Backen!
Okay, so das reicht. Und jetzt gebe ich da noch Erdbeersoße drauf.
Ihr könnt die noch süßen wenn die Erdbeeren nicht süß genug waren, bei mir waren sie jetzt süß genug.
Und dann gebe ich auch noch frische Erdbeeren mit dazu. Ohh, das sieht hübsch aus!
Jetzt schneide ich hier noch ein paar frische Erdbeeren.
Ich find's wunderwunderschön!
Und ganz ehrlich: Es ging soo schnell!
Also ich habe jetzt keine 45min gebraucht, mit allem. Mit Backzeit, mit allem!
45min, und ich glaube die Zeit hat jeder.
Aber es wäre cool, wenn ihr das jetzt noch mal so 'n Stündchen ziehen lasst.
Oder macht das gerne am Vorabend, das ist auch kein Problem.
Ich lasse das Ganze gleich den Hamza probieren.
Hamza, du musst gleich probieren. Ist mir egal was du sagst!
[Hamza] Mhh ich weiß nicht!
[Kiki] Der hatte jetzt 1 Monat Pause.
[Hamza] Ich bin außer Form Kiki!
Hamza hatte jetzt 1 Monat durch Ramadan, durch den Fastenmonat..
Der hat jetzt 1 Monat keinen Taste Test gemacht, das geht nicht!
Also Leute, ich verabschiede mich an der Stelle.
Ich wünsche euch viel Freude beim Nachmachen und bleibt ihr dran wenn ihr den Taste Test von Hamza sehen möchtet!
Und dann bin ich mal hinter der Kamera und filme das Ganze.
Ich wünsche euch noch einen wunderschönen Tag und sage: Bis zum nächsten Mal auf Kikis Kitchen, Tschüss!
Taste Test! Nicht im Wohnzimmer, sondern in der Küche und Kiki ist hinter der Kamera.
Warum kommst du eigentlich nicht hierhin? Warum muss ich alleine hier stehen?
[Kiki] Ganz ehrlich: Ich will dich einfach mal alleine vor der Kamera sehen!
[Hamza] Wie bestellt und nicht abgeholt!
[Hamza] Komm doch, zusammen! Egal, ich ess alleine.
Also wir haben hier eine Erdbeer-Tiramisu-Trilece...
[Kiki] Nein, bitte nenn es nicht Tiramisu!
Ja okay, ich probier's. Weißt du was?
Ich will gar nicht viel reden, ich probier's einfach!
M-hm, m-hm. Sehr sommerlich, leicht und voll weich.
Also - oh, sorry!
[Kiki] Was hast du gemacht? *lacht*
[Hamza] Da ist ein Stück runtergefallen!
Also ich finde den Kuchen von der Süße her eigentlich sehr, sehr gut.
Also du hast jetzt nicht viel Zucker reingemacht, ne?
[Kiki] Nee. Ist die Süße gut oder kann man ein bisschen mehr Zucker..?
Ich glaube je älter ich werde, desto weniger Zucker möchte ich! Und jetzt ist der Fall gerade, dass ich die Süße super finde.
[Kiki] Also soll man nichts ändern an der Süße?
Nö, kannst du genauso lassen! Ich find den super weich und fluffig.
Und sehr milchig!
[Kiki] *lacht*
Weißt du was cool ist? Das schmeckt so in der Art..
Erdbeermilchshake!
[Kiki] *lacht*
[Hamza] Ist so!
Was denn?
*lacht*
Als hättest du so'n Teig in Erdbeermilchshake reingetan!
[Kiki] Okay, das hört sich gut an!
[Kiki] Ich merk schon du hörst gar nicht auf, zu essen also heißt das, es bekommt 10 von 10, oder?
Gibt nie 'ne Punktzahl aber ich find's lecker!
[Kiki] *lacht*
Obwohl ich nicht so der Erdbeertyp bin, ne?
[Kiki] Nee eigentlich nicht, das stimmt!
Also Leute, unbedingt nachmachen!
Ich find's auch krass - Ich glaube, ich könnte das ganze Blech essen jetzt!
Die ganze Auflaufform. Also ich find das ist voll leicht im Magen.
[Kiki] Du musst in die Kamera gucken, du guckst mich die ganze Zeit an!
Ja sorry, ich hab nur Augen für dich statt für die Kamera! Warum soll ich die Kamera angucken?
So Leute, sorry!
Normalerweise wollen Frauen immer angeguckt werden. Okay, dann guck ich jemand anderes halt an!
Also Kamera, unbedingt nachmachen!
Probiert's aus und ich fand's lecker! Abonnieren und liken nicht vergessen.
Komm her, kriegst 'n Klatschi.
Klatschi und Boxi!
So, nächstes Mal bist du neben mir. Sonst macht's keinen Spaß alleine.
Ciao ciao!